gonna lighten things up a bit with some
tweets we found that we would like for
you to respond to and keep in mind these
are all
real comments let's start with the ones
from your time
on before the 90 days okay the first one
i feel like rebecca and zied have worn
the same outfit
for like four weeks now i
have a ridiculous amount of jackets but
when you're packing for a month in
another country
and you have to lug luggage through you
know
15 airports you felt like um you pair it
down
okay i brought one jacket it's just one
jacket so she does have more than one
jacket
yes okay we have another one another
tweet
finally an american is catfishing a
foreigner
rebecca is a real hero now we talked
about the photo shopping
that's really good photo shopping but i
think you're prettier in person
thank you thank you um
yeah i mean it was just an app and you
can just hit a button and it makes you
look like that
you do look kind of like a little barbie
doll on the right it did something cool
to my nose it made my nose like really
long and skinny and i was like i've
never even wanted a nose job and now i
want a nose job which i'm not doing but
i loved that comment
you did yeah so why don't you read the
next one okay
funny how the ed looks like a cast
member from west side story all of a
sudden
can't wait for him to say things like
zee's making me very much angry he does
people are so creative he does get his
hair kind of hot yeah
okay we have another one
if only was he had worked so hard
as the buttons on his sweater oh bless
his heart
okay so throughout the entire uh before
the 90 day season
i was constantly having to defend the
fact that all of his shirts were too
tight
do you think they're too tight yes you
do 100 yeah okay
yeah and i have um i have went shopping
without him
and bought him clothes that fit him
correctly and he won't wear them
[Music]